we don't see things how they are we see
things how we are and so I don't like to
use the word visualization because I
think it's been getting's been overused
I like to use the word mental rehearsal
I don't care if you're a virtuoso uh
musician I don't care if you are a
performer or an actor I don't care if
you're a dancer or an athlete everybody
does this who's engaged in getting
better at whatever they do they will
rehearse or they'll re rehearse the ACT
enough times that the once they can
concept the whole thing to its
completion and they get out of that
think box then the think box is so
important because we have to review our
act we have to repeat it enough times
and the act of mental rehearsal really
installs the neurological Hardware in
your brain it primes the brain free so
you have circuits to use hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's learn
how to use the power of thought to
attract the things that you want enjoy
mental rehearsal also changes the body
you can take a group of men
and have them imagine or rehearse doing
bicep curls for an hour a day for two
weeks and add an emotional component
called stronger harder more intense and
for one hour they practice in their mind
doing those those curls
at the end of two weeks there's a 13.5
increase in muscle strength they never
lifted weight their bodies changing by
thought alone so the person who's
priming their brain and body through
rehearsal
when they get in their play box there's
no thinking they're just doing there's
just the act in fact the thought of what
they're doing becomes the experience
they get lost in the act and they're
analytical facilities their analytical
mind is out of the way and they can they
can sustain a state where nothing in
their environment is going to move them
from the state they're in the feeling of
what it would feel like to play well and
they hold on to that feeling and when
the conditions get tense they actually
do something different they
self-regulate and they actually crave
this moment of performance to be able to
produce an outcome and so there's no
mysticism to this it's just what people
do when they get really into something
is that we rehearse all the time so but
people understand if you take a group of
people who've never played the piano
before and you teach them one hand that
scales them chords and they come in
practice for two hours a day for five
days at the end of five days if you do a
brain stand and before and after they'll
grow circuits on the opposite side of
the brain no magic there you learn
something new learning's making new
connections you get your body involved
you get some instruction you have an
experience experience enriches the
circuits repeat it over and over again
fire and wire and pay attention and stay
present you'll assemble new neurological
circuitry
take another group of people have them
close their eyes an act that actually
have them mentally rehearse playing the
scales and chords for two hours a day
for five days scan their brain before
and after in the end of five days their
brain will look like they've been
playing the piano for five days but they
never lifted a finger the brain
literally changed through the rehearsal
okay so now take the person and put them
in front of a piano never played the
piano before and they could actually
play those scales and chords like the
people who are actually physically
demonstrating it so what does that have
to do for the single mother of three
children what does that have to do with
the person
who's trying to heal a health condition
it's not enough to just have a good
meditation and get up and spend the rest
of your day reacting and responding to
the conditions in your life that's one
hour of living or conditioning your body
and brain into the future against 15
hours of you and responding emotionally
from your past so we got to rehearse
okay how am I going to be in this
situation how am I going to change
what would love do today what would
greatness look like it's the it's those
frontal lobe questions that actually
begins to install the circuitry and we
all do it naturally the only time we
don't do it is when we're living in
stress and we're living in survival why
because it's not a time to create it's
not a time to learn it's not a time to
go inward it's not and not a time to
Dream It's a time to run fight and hide
and if you're spending the majority of
your time
in the arousal of those stress hormones
than most people then their senses
become heightened they narrow their
focus and now they're engaged in doing
anything they can relying on something
outside of them to take away that
feeling so if people begin to understand
that they actually can change and
there's a they understand a formula to
do it and they practice that formula and
they rehearse it both by mentally
rehearsing it and actually participating
in it the effects should be in the
experiment that something should change
either in your body or in your life and
that's why we do it so when you see the
changes or the synchronicities or the
coincidences or the opportunities
starting to show up in your life you're
going to pay attention to what you did
and you're going to do it again and many
people who have chronic health
conditions that just get Beyond those
thoughts and those habits and those
emotions that keep them as that same
personality and begin to think act and
feel differently
notice dramatic changes in their in
their health and in their biology and we
have the data to suggest that people who
do this for seven days their body looks
like genetically and biologically
they're in a different life their body
is no longer responding in the same way
and they're no longer victims to their
environment because they can
self-regulate there tends to be a
greater resistance
uh to anything in their environment even
on a microscopic level rule number two
is be grounded in the energy of
Stillness with Gabby Bernstein in
Stillness I receive
okay I'm going to take that one in
Stillness I receive
for those of you who have a meditation
practice for those of you who have had
those moments on your meditation pillow
or in a yoga studio during shavasana
when you hear that intuitive Voice come
through saying
do that thing or call that person or
leave that job or leave that marriage
those moments come to us when we ground
ourselves in the energy of Stillness
when we become silent in our mind when
our nervous system becomes still enough
to receive intuitive vibrational
thoughts when our
vibration as Abraham Hicks would say our
vibration gets into alignment with the
universe and so we often think that we
will get the big ideas or make a lot
happen by moving a lot by doing a lot by
by not being still
but what we learned here on dear Gabby
is it's really the opposite it's in that
Stillness in that receptive energy that
receptivity zone
that we begin to hear intuitive guidance
that we begin to see uh possibilities
unfolding that we start to feel a deeper
connection to our own inner guidance
system and we can trust it
we can trust it
it's also in that Stillness that we
receive not only information and
guidance but it's also how we receive
our manifestations
so
you may not even be consciously aware of
what's manifesting around you because
you're moving so freaking fast
and when you stop moving and sit still
quiet your mind through meditation
release your control through prayer
that is when you will genuinely receive
you will receive the gifts that the
universe is always ready to offer you
you will receive the messages that you
are ready to hear
you will receive
the exact guidance that you need
so your job isn't to do do your job is
to sit the F down and listen rule number
three is change the way you think with
Jack Canfield The Law of Attraction just
for review The Law of Attraction says
this it says that whatever you think
about focus on fantasize about worry
about talk about attend to watch on TV
listen to on the radio you're going to
create more of in your life especially
those things you feel intense feelings
about so when you're talking about how
bad it is and you're not feeling good
about it you're really upset about it
and you're down in the bar you know
talking about how terrible life is what
I call the ain't it awful Club you know
people go there after work to the end of
awful club and complain about how
miserable their life is and when you do
that what happens is you actually create
more of that because you're sending out
a vibration and that vibration is your
thoughts and your feelings that are the
result of those thoughts and so we have
to become conscious of our thoughts we
have to become conscious of our feelings
we have to become deliberate thinkers
deliberate creators you know this works
like this we've all had this experience
where you've been in a room and you've
seen two pianos you've probably seen
this on TV or maybe if you're a music
student you hit a c chord on one piano
and the same strings on the other piano
start to vibrate without even hitting
them and so there's this thing called
harmonic resonance if we had a bunch of
tuning Forks in the room and we hit an a
fork over here all the other a Forks
would start to vibrate and that's how
Law of Attraction works when you're
putting out an emotion when you're
having a feeling when you're
communicating about something what
happens is the vibration level you're at
all remember the Beach Boys Good Vibes
you know good good good vibrations right
and so when we have the Good Vibrations
when we're happy when we're feeling
abundant when we're feeling generous
when we're feeling
um loving when we're feeling
appreciative and we're feeling abundant
what happens in life is we attract more
of that to us because we start all the
things in universe that are vibrating at
the level that would allow us to
continue to feel that way and they start
to vibrate and become attractive to us
if you walk in a room and there's
someone over there A lot of people are
laughing and you like to laugh you're
attracted to the laughter some people
hear the laughter and they go I don't
want to be with those people and they go
over with the people that are
commiserating over by the bar
and we've all seen that happen and so we
literally do attract toward each other
at the same vibration I remember being
on in Hawaii on a vacation and I noticed
all the people wearing the Tommy Bahama
shirts would all kind of gather together
you know and all the people wearing the
the polo shirts you know the old money
they would gather together and then
you'd see the people with the t-shirts
that said drinking problem
I don't have a drinking problem I get
drunk I fall down I get back up again no
problem right
and they would find each other and so
we're attracted to people that are
vibrating at the same level that we are
and if we want to be more successful we
have to begin to think and act like
those people who are being more
successful you want to be thin hang out
with the people that are thinner and do
the things that are doing think the
thoughts they think you want to be
spiritual hang out with the people that
are more spiritual you go to a retreat
go to church if you want to be more
athletic you go to the gym and you work
out with other people and as you are
attracted to people that are I'll call
these call it one level up you know if
you're making fifty thousand dollars a
year you want to be thinking the kind of
thoughts that a hundred thousand dollar
a year person thinks but how do you do
that you have to get into their sphere
of influence you have to think like they
think and you can read books about it
you can listen to audio programs about
it you can join those people and listen
to their conversation you can get into
their sphere of influence you know as
you're watching this program you're in
that sphere of influence there's a
vibration that's being created here so
it's not about you it's not about having
stuff it's about being in a state of
consciousness that then attracts things
that are at that same level of
Consciousness so if I'm in a state of
appreciation in a state of love I'm
going to attract more things to
appreciate and more things to love in my
life if I'm in a state of whining and
complaining about how bad it is then
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
track more things people and situations
to complain and whine about so it's very
critical that we become
deliberate about the thoughts we think
and we're going to talk a little more
about how to do that as we go through
this I'm going to teach you how to do
that now thoughts are very powerful
thoughts are the most powerful things we
have it's a great tool remember in
school when I said think harder
all right go back to you Matt you think
harder you'll figure this out you go
how to learn to control our thoughts but
our thoughts that your thinking now are
thoughts that are controlling our future
the thoughts you think today are
creating the future you're going to have
tomorrow if you want to know what you
were thinking a year ago look at what's
going on in your life right now you've
attracted that by the thoughts you were
thinking the only thing that's going to
change your future is by choosing to
think a different set of thoughts
choosing a different set of imagination
pictures in your head choosing a
different set of actions choosing a
different set of behaviors and what you
say that's the only thing that you have
any control over is your thoughts the
imagination you you think about the
pictures in your head and what you say
and do and so we have to realize that we
are very much controlling our future and
our own destiny by the thoughts we think
and you can learn to deliberately create
whatever you want by learning to change
your life doesn't matter what your
current situation is you can change it
there are no limitations they're only
Limitless possibilities in your life and
I know this is true because it's true in
my own life little Jackie Canfield from
Wheeling West Virginia
and here I am today this International
Celebrity also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is attract positivity
with John assarath A lot of people
who watched me and the other teachers in
the movie The Secret
I think simplified the law of attraction
into thinking that all you've got to do
is you know think about making more
money believe that you can achieve
earning more money
and then more money is going to be
attracted to you somehow through some
mysterious process
almost as if you know thinking and
believing is the only thing that's
needed in order to make the money that
you want to make
and I think a lot of people were set off
on the wrong path to making the Law of
Attraction work for them and so let me
give you a couple of things on how you
can exponentially attract more money
through understanding a little bit more
about energy a little bit more about the
process of manifestation so if you're
ready when we go to the fundamental fact
that everything is energy you are energy
the computer or cell phone you're
watching me on is made up of tiny little
bits of photons vibrating packets of
energy we call that quanta
but if it was just enough to you know to
think and believe you know that money's
going to be attracted to you everybody
would be rich wouldn't they they'd have
beautiful houses nice cars they go on
vacations everywhere and there would be
a financial abundance windfall for
everybody but why do most people who
believe in the Law of Attraction not end
up being rich financially
and the answer is it's a little bit more
complex than the surface of what was
covered in the movie so let me give you
a couple of things to think about and do
when we're dealing with money you've got
to remember yes money is just an idea uh
we use uh coins and chocolates and
seashells and livestock and we Bartered
and traded you know one thing for
another like bread for teeth cleaning or
working on a horse's Hooves you know for
something that somebody else needed in a
small village or town so going back in
time to the beginning you know when we
even came up with this concept of money
money was created as a means of exchange
between people money wasn't ever thought
of as something that just popped into
your lap or into your life just because
you were meditating or visualizing you
know or hoping and praying and wishing
that you had more money it's a means of
exchange however there are some things
to focus on
if money is energy and let's call that
the spiritual side of energy and we know
that there is more than enough money for
everybody there's there's uh signs of
money and you know in cash and coins and
Golds and buildings and real estate
um in products and services that
represent money we know there's more
than enough of it
the key to getting the Law of Attraction
into uh into motion is thinking of it
slightly differently and instead of
thinking of the Law of Attraction
something that you know is attracted to
you like a magnet
think of it as the law of resonance
something that when you become in
resonance with
then there is more than enough and so
the question is
how do I become in resonance with more
money
so first and foremost I want to teach
you a model called semp
s-e-m-p and it stands for Spiritual
emotional mental and physical and since
you're into the Law of Attraction you
probably believe that everything is
energy and that there is a spiritual
side to your being and and a governance
of this incredible you know universe and
planets Etc
so let's assume that the spiritual
intelligence is within you and within
everybody else and in all things in all
places at all times it's omnipotent and
omnipresent right and as I say this my
Chimes are dinging maybe that's because
that's the truth
if that's the beginning of the Law of
Attraction get in resonance with
abundance get in resonance with the
genius Part of Yourself get in resonance
with the people the tools the resources
that are here right now that will help
you achieve more income more wealth part
one part two is the E part of Seb
emotions what if you got emotionally
connected to achieving the financial
goals that you want to have what if you
picked a financial goal that you wanted
to achieve and then you started to feel
as if that was already happening is it
possible
that by getting emotionally connected to
that money to that wealth to that income
you're increasing the amplitude of the
vibration of you your 100 trillion cells
governed by your brain which we'll get
to in a minute and is it possible that
you have a financial goal and you see
yourself in your mind's eye and you feel
yourself achieving that Financial goal
that you can become in Harmony in
resonance with that income that goal is
it possible just think for just a moment
I'll wrap it all up in about three or
four minutes so the S is the abundance
the E is the emotion now let's get into
mindset
your mental faculties earlier we
mentioned you know think and believe
but what happens if you believe that
it's possible but you also believe that
maybe you're too young or too old or
maybe you believe you don't have the
knowledge or the skills or maybe you
believe that you know it's easy for
other people but not for you or maybe
you believe you don't have the education
or maybe you believe that you don't
deserve it or maybe you believe that
it's not the right timing if you have a
positive desire goal or vision
and you have disempowering limiting
beliefs or a self-image that doesn't
really really believe that you deserve
it what may be happening is that you are
not in coherence or in Harmony in your
mind and in your heart and that means
that even though you may be sending out
these signals okay for the abundance the
money the income the wealth that you
want if either at the neurological level
the Heart level or the gut level you
don't really really really believe for
whatever reason that you can achieve
that goal or have that goal goal or have
that lifestyle then you are creating a
chaotic vibration between your physical
body your emotions your mindset and in
this field of intelligence shall we call
it so so so far we've talked about
spiritual emotional mental and I've only
touched scratched the surface of this
but now let's talk about the physical
side of it do you remember earlier
I suggested that we developed money as a
means of exchange between people
companies governments Etc well if you
want to have more money the question now
becomes are you doing the right things
in the right order in the physical world
to be able to create this circle this
this exchange mechanism where you are
providing your products your knowledge
your services to others in exchange for
money you see when people aren't in
total resonance spiritually emotionally
mentally and physically
chances are that the Law of Attraction
will not work for them and since we Are
Spiritual Beings having a human
experience and we have emotions and we
are able to control our mental models
and our mindset we can control the fears
that we have of failure or being
disappointed or embarrassed or ashamed
or ridiculed because those are the
things that hold us back from achieving
our financial goals and life goals
the more you learn how to get
incoherence in harmony
the easier making more money becomes and
most people are never taught this
Advanced model called semp so that they
can earn more have more live more give
more be more
and they keep thinking that the law of
attraction is think believe and you'll
achieve that's baloney
there are a variety of advanced
methodologies that you can learn to get
into total Harmony total coherence with
earning two times three times four times
five times more income having the wealth
that allow you to have the financial
Freedom the choice freedom to pursue the
things that you really want to pursue in
your life rule number five is feel the
fullness of life with Eckhart Tolle is
there some type of discipline that is
needed to be successful with conscious
manifestation if so can you describe or
the discipline is that is needed
foreign
well basically I have already described
the discipline that's needed for in your
daily life
to be able to be aware of yourself and
of your own state of consciousness
uh
also an important factor perhaps that is
implied in what we've been saying but
it's worth pointing it out
explicitly
is the importance of
what is conventionally called
gratitude
but there could be other words
gratitude is a very powerful
transformation or tool and also one of
the most powerful
tools for manifesting
better things in your life
now what does that mean the Gratitude is
to to acknowledge
the good in your life now
and you it's surprising
how many people don't do that
who can only see the bad in their lives
or only complain but it's a extremely
powerful to acknowledge the goods that's
in your life now
let's talk about this for a moment
the this does not mean
let you have a conceptual idea
of what your life is
and then you compare it to somebody
else's life
and you say oh really I should be happy
because I have it so much better than
look at these people
they've got their life it's worse than
mine so I really should be grateful for
for my life that's not it
that's not real gratitude that that
means you're you're moving within the
conceptual realm and
the the feeling of well-being
is dependent on somebody else
who has less than you are suffering more
than you
so gratitude is not if you compare
yourself because that's a misconception
very common misconception of gratitude
is you compare yourself to somebody else
or even a whole group of people who say
you look at people in the third world I
really should be grateful we are so much
better off even though I may be poor but
I'm still better off than feet so let's
be grateful no that's not real gratitude
you're depending on others to be worse
off than you Lord you can feel gratitude
it's crazy it's it feeds the ego
no gratitude is
to acknowledge the good that's in your
life now now this moment okay so it's
not the good in your life situation I'm
I'm fine because I have achieved this or
that or whatever no at this moment
and that's simple things it really comes
down to Simple Things
what can I be grateful for at this
moment
wow there's so much
I can be grateful for
now what is it to be grateful is to to
acknowledge something to give it
attention
and to appreciate it
I have a this you can't see it but have
a nice round table here
let's see in this lovely I touch it it's
made of wood
and it's it's lovely
it's not spectacular it doesn't need to
be spectacular but it's
it has a presence into beingness
this light coming through the window
there and from behind me I often sit
here I I'm lucky to have have these
trees here and I often sit here there's
a little screen to
otherwise it's there's too much glare
but
I often say to you I look at the trees
for 10 15 minutes
and there's a continuous feeling of
goodness because in this culture you
could call that gratitude but it's I
don't I don't say my mind I'm so
grateful for these trees I simply
appreciate the the Wonder and aliveness
the beingness of these trees
so I acknowledge the Good In This Moment
by appreciating the the uh the Wonder
the Miracle at the of these trees it's
just uh you can look at the sky to here
today happens to be completely overcast
but very often and that's fine too
because this
this light filtering continues through
there's more light in a way today than
is on when the sky is blue because the
light is dispersed by the cloud it's
it's everywhere it's it's and it runs
from the Sun it filled us through the
clouds you now you appreciate that
do you look at a potted plant
[Music]
you become you're grateful for that
you're grateful for all the little
things
you hear bird
oh
you drank a glass of water
acknowledging all the your breathing
[Music]
so that's gratitude it's the the
Gratitude is the appreciation of life
that's around you annual number six the
last time before some very special bonus
Clips is be in an Innovative state with
Dean graziosi Peter Drucker said
Innovation and marketing are the only
two things when it comes to business the
rest are all expenses right so
innovation
adapting is the most important thing to
where you want to go you know Wayne
Gretzky said something great when he was
asked why he was such a great hockey
player anybody know what Wayne Gretzky
said why he was so good at hockey he was
one of the greatest hockey players of
all time for those who don't follow
hockey I'm not a big I don't follow
hockey but I love seeing the greats most
some people skate to where the puck was
most people skate to where the puck is I
found a way to skate to where the puck
is going if you are not in an Innovative
state if you're not learning to adapt
and shift when something like a variant
that was announced four days ago can
have shut down the country again you got
to realize we are in a new world if
you're doing things the way you used to
do and you're not ready to shift and
adapt then you're already losing out
you're already losing ground
and think about it
I don't know about you but when my
confidence is down
when I'm watching the news when I'm
seeing the world chip when your
confidence is down it is hard to think
about pivoting correct it's hard to
think about adapting correct it's hard
to get in Flow State and be Innovative
so we need to keep ourselves around
people who are innovating who have
already innovated before who continue to
innovate who can adapt and adjust pivot
and keep moving forward because if
you're howling around people that say
hey we're just going to wait to see how
things go think about that
you know think about the book who moves
my cheese
right everybody on the concept of who
Moved My Cheese right A Couple Of Mice
the cheese coming every day they're
loving it all of a sudden the cheese
stops one mouse goes hell I'm gonna wait
right here until they bring me my cheese
back and the other one's like I don't
think so I'm getting a little hungry I'm
gonna go look for some cheese uh you're
crazy just stay right here and wait what
happened to the the the mouse that
waited he starved to death the other one
had to go down a couple tunnels probably
get lost figure stuff out eventually
found more cheese this is a time do not
wait for your cheese to come back you
must go out and find new cheese you know
when they say when one door closes
another one opens it sounds so magical
like oh it's locked let me go through
this next door no you usually grab the
handle and go ah let me back in please
let me in right
but do you really want what's behind
your old door
think about that question
do you really want what's behind your
old door
you're here today
because you want to go through the next
tour you want another level impact more
do more be more
I'd love for you to think about that
innovation
adapting
if you're not where the puck is going
then you're just doing what everybody
else does
and how many people do you think are
trying to do this on their own I can
tell you a story really quick I'm gonna
speed this up a little bit but I think
of innovation when covet first came
there was two restaurants in Utah and a
friend of mine told me this story they
were about six miles apart covet comes
shuts everybody down one guy gets really
pissed I can't believe this is happening
it's the president's fault it's China's
fault was blaming everybody else pissed
off sends everybody home I could I could
visualize like his arms crossed six
miles down the road a couple streets
over
another guy the world shuts down he and
his brother go to Lowe's or Home Depot
and they build an outside Pavilion so
you could drive through and they made
their restaurant a barbecue restaurant
to a drive-through they went inside and
moved everything around six feet apart
so they could bring people back to work
within three days they were back to work
within a week he said there was a mile
along the line of people waiting to get
the barbecue
what's the difference of the two guys
there was still covet the world was shut
down they lived in the same city they
were on the same street just about six
miles apart they both served food all
completely equal one got Innovative one
adapted and one could you imagine their
story in five years one's like damn it
covet ruined everything for me and the
other one's like well we have 65
restaurants drive-throughs because of
covet
lemons lemonade out of lemons but you
have to be in that Innovative adaptive
mode
I want to explain something to you that
not many people really understand I want
to talk about the law of attraction
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if I let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is law of
gravity anything heavier than Earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work well I use a
diagram to explain the mind now let this
circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now I want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration if you looked at your
body through a microscope you'd see that
energy dancing right before your eyes
and here's something that will keep you
thinking for the next 20 years when you
move out of it the body does not stop
moving if you go to a funeral parlor and
pick up the remains and look at it you
will see it moving and if it wasn't
moving how would it ever change the Dust
you move into your body and you will
move up and it's how you use your mind
that's going to dictate the vibration
you're in now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here and that separates the conscious
mind from the subconscious mind
now this subconscious mind has been
programmed when you're a little baby
this is the way it was so just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm now a
paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for Generations now I'm going
to say that the Paradigm is X-Type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think and you can
think anything you want to think
and as you think you build ideas there's
a power that's flowing into your
Consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think
X-Type thoughts therefore you're going
to be in an X-Type vibration
and that will produce X-Type results now
it's the results you want to change and
to change the results you're going to
have to change what you attract you see
the thoughts that you think control the
vibration that you're in vibration is
nothing but an idea it's a law of the
universe everything vibrates nothing
rests we live in an ocean of motion and
it's the thoughts that you're thinking
that you impress upon your subconscious
mind that control the vibration the
body's in and that dictates how you act
but it also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's a
infinite number of frequencies but you
and I operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned into the vibration you're in now
it's the Paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change our thinking but that
doesn't do anything you've got to change
the paradigm and if you don't change the
Paradigm nothing happens now talking
about paradigms is another subject we'll
do that at another time but it's the
thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this it's the Paradigm that's
causing the problem you can think a Y
type thought which is totally different
than the X-Type conditioning it isn't
going to go anywhere because when you go
to get emotionally involved and this is
the emotional mind when you go to get
emotionally involved with that white
type done the Paradigm will kick it out
do you know why it's so uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort but understand this
the Paradigm in the thinking control the
vibration you're in and the vibration
you're in is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
Consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in the results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this you've got to
change the vibration you're in and your
whole world changes listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what I tell you he was
giving me y-type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but I did
exactly what he said and you know
something my income went from 4 000 to
175 000 in a year and then I took it
over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what I'm showing you watch this
over and over and over again there's a
number of lessons in here everything we
as human beings have created
on this planet
but essentially fuss created in our
minds
all that you see which is human work on
this planet
first found expression in the mind then
it got manifested
in the outside world
[Music]
the wonderful things that we have done
on this planet
and the horrible things that we have
done on this planet both have come from
the human mind so if we are concerned as
to what we create in this world it's
extremely important that first of all we
learn to create the right things in our
mind how we keep our minds if we do not
have the power to keep our minds the way
we want it
what we create in the world is also
going to be very accidental and
haphazard
so learning to create our minds the way
we want is the basis of creating the
world the way we want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
law
on a certain day
a man took a walk he went for a long
walk
accidentally unawares he walked into
Paradise fortunate isn't he
he just took a walk and he landed up in
Paradise
after this long walk he felt a little
tired
so he thought oh I'm tired I wish I
could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was very cushiony
grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and slept
after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh I am well
rested but I'm feeling hungry I wish I
had something to eat
and he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him
you need to understand they have the
services like that
[Music]
don't ask questions
came and he ate
stomach became full then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to drink
[Music]
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink he thought about it and all of
them just appeared
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know Charles Darwin told you all of
you are monkeys your tail fell away not
me Charles Darwin told you that you were
all monkeys and your tail fell away and
then you became human yes definitely the
tail fell away but the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as murkata which means a monkey
why we are referring to the Mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey
one thing about a monkey is it's a
necessary moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is if
I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to learn it from the
monkey you can teach it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
Mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
I asked for food food came
I asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghosts came
all the ghosts have come they're going
to surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghost surrounded him and
started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me and he
died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kalpa rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghost
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest you can barely
find a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of some yukti
is referred to as a cultivation
if you organize your mind to a certain
level of organization it in turn
organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything gets organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and the
fundamental life energies are organized
in One Direction once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in One Direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds and in turn
organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now in One Direction if
you do this you are a kalpa Brookshire
yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important
that our physical action emotional
action mental action and energy actions
are controlled and properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they ask for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
the true for them
generally this happens to people who are
in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh I want to build
a house to build a house I need 50 lakhs
but I have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you're
also saying I don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith in a God or
in a temple or whatever
who is how simple-minded Faith Works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people
who are too much thinking for them it
never works a childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
this things are completely removed by
the simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
so is Shiva going to come and build your
house no I want you to understand God
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as God he's a source
of creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible is something possible or
not possible is destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive but what
you want what is fear is fear something
that you should fear no
I want you to imagine as you're driving
down the street in your car
and a light pops up on the dashboard
pops up
um
have you ever taken a hammer and hit the
light because you don't like the light
of course not that would be silly right
what if the light on the dashboard was
just a signal maybe you're low on tire
air uh air pressure maybe you're missing
air or water in your windshield wiper
maybe the back trunk door is open isn't
the signal in your car
just for you to be aware that maybe
something is wrong or something needs
attention
is it possible that if we stop thinking
of fear as the enemy fear is one of your
biggest friends why well when you
understand how did this organism
okay develop and how does it keep us
alive
it pays attention to things okay in your
external World triggers from your
external word that could cause your
death or distraction it causes you to do
what when there is a Potential
Threat predator or threat at the door it
lights up the fear signals since
cortisol epinephrine or norepinephrine
into your bloodstream so you either know
how to fight it you run away or you
freeze hoping that the Predator will go
away so when your brain every brain
gets this signal that there is a threat
at the door
it sends a signal
in the form of a neurochemical that you
feel
now if somebody
feels this threat in their body but they
don't know how to manage the emotion we
call fear let's say there's a fear that
you have a failure and what it might
mean to your family what's what about a
fear of losing money and not having
enough to pay the rent the mortgage or
for retirement what if there's a fear of
trying something and then it not working
out and you're embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed or rejected or judged oh my
God if you judge me then you're gonna
reinforce my low self-esteem of myself
and then knowledge then who am I
you understand what's happening in the
circuits I'm just describing
so when our brain has this Fierce
circuit activated do you think the fear
circuit causes you to go oh hey let's
take action anyway or do you think it
goes high alert high alert high alert be
aware what's going on what if you fail
what if you succeed what if succeed and
fail whenever that circuit is triggered
motivational circuit shuts down whenever
that circuit is activated your thinking
circuit shuts down all the blood flow
goes into a part of your brain to help
you do what possibly run away protect
yourself it's a protection mechanism but
here is what I want you to remember this
automatic trigger and circuit has been
evolving for millions of years but your
specific experiences since you were born
in the modeling experiential and the
um and the imprinting years caused you
to have
beliefs about things some Empower you
some disempower let me give you an
example
okay let me give you an example when I
say the word
or let me give you a different uh the
same example with just a little
different story
if I say to you that I'd like to take a
big snake about five feet long and let
it Slither across your arm and around
your neck and it's a python how many of
you go oh wow that would be great
versus how many of you are going oh my
God let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run versus oh
my God that would be great to take a
picture of me with it so I put on social
media
so is it really the snake that is the
threat or is it your Concept in your
brain the meaning that you have
associated with a snake that is
activating for some of you the reward
center and for others the fear Center
same stake stained stimuli there isn't
even a snake here I just add you think
about it
right and it triggered that fear circuit
for some reward circuit for others so
it's never about the thing so when we
have fear of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed judged uh fear of
disappointing ourselves fear of failing
fear of succeeding there's 50 different
types of fears we automatically trigger
the circuit that does what stops our
action taking your personality literally
ad is made up of how you think how you
act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck it's
really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called the memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to you
the stronger of a hold it has over you
yeah well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on extended
periods of time so that the event
produces a chemical change and the body
needs to return back to homeostasis or
balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the moon so you say Ed what's
wrong with you I'm in the mood why are
you in a mood well this thing happened
to me five days ago and I'm having one
long emotional reaction so then what you
do is you keep telling the story about
it keep firing and wiring the same
circuits and you keep conditioning the
body into the past so then you wake up
in the morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well tell me the story now the latest
research on memory says that 50 percent
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have just to reaffirm that they can't
change right wow so then what's the
significance of this where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy period yes so then the stronger
the emotion that you have the some
problem or condition or person in your
life the more you're paying attention to
them so they captured your attention so
you're giving your power hour away wow
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electronic magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then teach
a person then how to trade that emotion
for an elevated emotion now trade the
emotion for an elevated emotion right so
you're going to give that up and you're
going to practice feeling gratitude for
as an example yes the person says well I
can't feel gratitude and I say
absolutely you can because you don't
practice feeling it you practice
spending most of your time feeling
hatred and frustration so now it's going
to take a little time to cause that
heart of you to bloom or your heart of
yours to bloom once they're able to feel
even the smallest measure of gratitude
where they start feeling appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened where it's happening to you so
the moment you open your heart and you
feel gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life unless of the
victim of your life you have no idea
what you're capable of you have no idea
you have no idea the person you could be
the things you could accomplish the
things you can do the people you can
serve you've no idea that's why I don't
like 10-year goals 10-year goals think
about who you used to be 10 years ago
you know could that person accurately
with any with any degree of certainty
predict where you could be right now now
like if you're growing and you're
learning you're improving and you're
expanding you're invested in yourself
there's no way that you know where
you're going to be in one year let alone
five years or ten years you have no idea
what you're capable of and so it comes
down to questioning everything
the question what you can and can't do
you know we're told the story growing up
of what you should do and we're told
everything right you're told when to
show up and where to go and what to wear
and what to eat and what at what age you
should get married and what kind of
career you should go into right we're
told we should do all these things
you're told you're like who you know
nobody ever thought to ask us what we
want for our lives and you may not even
know and that's okay like you may know
where you want to go next but you may
not ultimately know the Final
Destination it's awesome
you know I think if you know the Final
Destination you're thinking small apart
from having a mission you know the
mission the purpose why do you do what
you do I want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough that's what I'm
chasing down every day
do I know where I'm going to be in a
year nope am I still making videos
probably but who knows I question
everything I want to I want people to
believe in themselves more what's the
best way to do that right now it's
through YouTube
but I think a lot of times people have
too certain of a plan and then they end
up
plain small because there's nothing
wrong with having goals and planes but
sometimes you need to jump off that if
you have a 10-year goal quite often you
need to jump off that goal two years in
because something better has come along
that actually better serves who you are
right now because the goal you set was
for who you used to be
you know if you felt that and so I'm
here at genius Network and this group of
super successful entrepreneurs that
meets once a month in masterminds and
talk about their business and pay a lot
of money to be a part of something like
this and every time I'm around people
who are who are having a high degree of
success
I always try to have them pick me apart
so when we when we do there's an
exercise called hot seats where you go
around the table and you basically share
what your biggest
what you think your biggest problem is
and whenever it gets to my turn I just
want people to ask me questions
because your biggest problem is you
don't know what your biggest problem is
right your biggest problem is you don't
know what your biggest problem is if you
know what your biggest problem was you
can go and solve it
for for entrepreneurs ambitious people
for you've got goals it's like
you don't know what the real problem is
the problem you think you have is a
problem you know the problem you think
you have yes very much is a problem but
there's a deeper problem underneath it
that you're missing
that I'm missing so this is where
question everything becomes important my
default has become instead of pretending
like I know everything and I know all my
problems that I don't know anything and
ask me questions and in the process of
asking me questions and learning about
me maybe you come up with some insight
that I've never seen before
everybody has their own way of
processing
um given advice you know so I'm around
people here everybody here has a seven
or eight figure nine figure business and
people here have sold their businesses
for nine figures crazy
awesome
and so they have their own way of
processing things and asking questions
and breaking somebody down
so instead of me coming in with
the question and having them trying to
fit into my box I'd rather fit into
theirs because in trying to understand
how they process things
it'll probably make me stretch and grow
and learn
and I'm probably going to get a better
result because they're going to see
something that I don't see
and so
in the process of questioning everything
when people can break you down and
you're open to it right because we're we
hold on to our identity like no that's
not going to work for me you know even
boom got a B I am allergic to bees
maybe I should question that I don't
feel like questioning that today though
do not want to get stung by a bee I once
got stung by a bee and uh only time in
my life I've been sung by bee and it I
was on the floor and my my back just
swelled up from the bee sting
um
anyway maybe question everything except
bee stings how about that uh there's
been times when people have given me
advice and it made sense and it really
fit and sometimes when it didn't
and and even if it doesn't make sense
what I'll default in my head the same is
this is either nothing like the person
didn't read me correctly or it's the
whole thing
think about if you're really opposed to
somebody's advice or feedback for you if
somebody gives you great advice like oh
wow that's really cool I should go and
do that cool they they met you where you
were at and you understand it
but there'll be other times when it it
doesn't feel right
and it could be that it just wasn't a
fit and they're giving you the wrong
advice or
you're so blind and this is what gets me
excited is maybe I'm so blind maybe I
believe my story so much that the thing
that you're talking about is actually
the whole thing like it's all I should
care about because figuring out how to
solve that because I'm so tied to my own
story that I'm not questioning enough
and coming back to the B Spot hopefully
it's gone I'm not questioning enough
and figuring that out becomes the the
whole unlock so a quick story on this I
did a life coaching session with
garyvee's lead coach Beth hendel and at
first I was shocked I didn't know I
didn't know garyvee had a life coach so
I was very excited to talk to her and
just like I've been explaining this
video I went through her process like
like how do you ask questions what do
you want to know about me I don't want
it to be if this is a coaching session
just treat me as a shoot me as a client
treat me as somebody who's going to
coach what do you need to know from my
story and how I act and I'm gonna I'm
gonna be as open as honest as possible
and what it led to was
a lot of the stuff she was saying
um was great but my single biggest
insight and takeaway was this and I'm
practicing this every single day now
the one takeaway that has honestly
changed my life
historically I've been the person who
believes in the plan
so what's my plan to get to the next
step like I want to go here what's my
plan what's my plan what's my plan so I
have the belief in the plan and I wake
up every day and I just do the plan
because I believe in the plan
I'll have some days where I don't
believe in a plan anymore like will this
plan help get me anywhere is this plan
still working like it's not working
anymore and that leads to some anxiety
for me because I believe in the plan and
when the plan doesn't work what happens
and so what I end up doing is making a
new plan
so I have a plan I believe in a plan
until I don't believe in it anymore
causes anxiety come up with a new plan
following so when creating a new plan
then I have certainty in the plan again
and I'm fine and I'm rock and rolling
but there are some days
there are some days when I can't come up
with a new plan the plan I have I don't
believe it anymore and I'm racking my
brain to come up with a new plan and I
can't come up with a new plan
if I'm the kind of person who believes
in the plane and then I can't come up
with a new plan that's a really uh
stress-inducing anxiety-filled place to
be and it doesn't happen that often
but when it does and I can't come up
with a new plan especially in the moment
while what I would end up telling myself
is great things happen to me you know
what you know what happened great things
happen to you
and I would use it as a self-soothing
mechanism as a coping mechanism
because I didn't want to just stay
locked because locked in that stress and
and it would be a downward spiral like
if I believe in the plan and the plan is
not working and I can't come up with a
new plan then I don't know what to do
with my life and that would create a
downward spiral I've never gone anywhere
close to depression or suicide but that
would lead to some dark that could lead
to some dark places and so the way that
I come out of it is just say great
things will happen to me great things
happen to me they already they always
happen to me great things happen to me
and I'll figure this out and that gives
me the Comfort to
move forward into the uncertainty and
then something will come that I will
solve it and what she said was garyvee's
life coach was
what you say to yourself
when you need that
self-soothing of great things happen to
you
needs to be your default state
so instead of believing in the plan as
your default State and only going to
great things happen to you when you are
at the lowest of your low
flip it to the point where great things
happen to you is the default
because that's where you're actually
your best self and I really felt that I
don't know how to do it
but even in questioning how do I do it
I just have to believe the great things
happen to me so a big part of my routine
now is is I don't know how many times
I'll I'll say that to myself feel that
great things happen to me I'm going to
put it as my new cell phone background
it's a it's a constant reminder even
making this video is another
reinforcement of it when people ask me
what my goals are there's been these
exercises we've been doing in genius
Network here and uh I just I just keep
reminding myself I don't know I don't
have a 10 year goal great things happen
to me
it's a constant reminder and I
I would I used to live it before this
awareness
I don't know like how many times would I
feel really down and low in
anxiety-filled that I couldn't come with
a new plan
maybe half of one percent of the time
like really small amounts and now I'm
probably living in great things happen
to me maybe
five percent of the time ten percent of
the time which is a huge jump from half
of one percent but it's still not my
default mode yet I'm still believing a
planned guy that's my ongoing challenge
to myself that's how I'm questioning
it's the willingness to question what
you're doing because what you're doing
right now has gotten you to where you're
at and if you're if you're happy with
where you're at cool but if you want
more you want to create more you want to
serve more you want to bring more you
want to help more you want more
you want to change and you have to
change
and the change starts with not just
questioning everything out there
question everything in here
questioning what you believe to be true
question who you think you are
questioning for sure what you think
you're capable of
because when you can get to the root of
that amazing things can happen here's
the hard truth about getting great
it takes time and dedication it takes a
willingness to accept that you're not
yet good enough it takes the ability to
stare at the places that you know that
you're weak to really look at those
things and not let it affect your sense
of self-esteem and not let it affect
your sense of self-worth so that you can
still get the momentum going but you
have to understand that in the beginning
we're all terrible
and as Henry Cartier brassonne said your
first 10 000 photographs are your worst
and so the thing that really makes great
art are the people that continue to push
and the people that continue to work and
face how inadequate they are and really
understand that at the end of the day
greatness is a craft greatness is a
process greatness is a habit greatness
is the little things that you do every
day over time going out every day
unafraid of whether or not this is one
of the ten thousand terrible things that
you're gonna do it's being unafraid to
make those mistakes is being unafraid
that you're not yet great
and as Marianne radmaker said courage
doesn't always Roar sometimes courage is
the quiet voice at the end of the day
saying I will try again tomorrow
and that's it if you want to be great
that's what you have to do you've got to
get up again tomorrow you've got to be
willing to face another day you've got
to be willing to accept that you've got
to get through the bad ideas before you
can get to the good you've got to
understand that you have to start as an
apprentice you have to start as a person
going and getting tea and you have to
accept that that's the job that you
should be playing that you should be
working for somebody else you should be
looking up to somebody else and seeing
what they can teach you because what you
know
is that you're there to learn what you
know is that you're there to get through
the 10
000 bad photographs that you need to get
through to ultimately achieve greatness
and if you make the catastrophic error
that's so many make
so try to tell the world that you're
extraordinary today to try to get the
world to follow you and look up to you
and think that you're something today
because the people that really win are
the ones that invest today the ones that
listen today the ones that spend every
ounce of their energy amassing Mastery
getting better every day working their
asses off to improve their skill set to
relentlessly look at the things that
they're not doing well to understand
that they have to break themselves down
and get rid of all of their ego before
they can really find greatness
those are the people that we remember
so if you want to be remembered if you
want to achieve real greatness
you just need to have the courage to
show up every day
and take another swing take another
photo
try another task do something that
scares you and do those little things
over and over and over until you win The
Voice Within us that believes that we
are not allowed to be happy
our card today is speaking to that
I believe I'm worthy of feeling good I
believe I am worthy of feeling good this
is often something that is a belief
system that sounds really nice but it's
actually far from our reality because
many of us have been brought up with the
belief system that we have to suffer to
succeed that we have to feel pain to
have purpose that we have to have
struggles in order to feel a sense of
Serenity in our life that is all quite
backwards it's when we feel good that we
actually attract more of what we want
into our life but we have to undo the
belief system that says who am I to feel
good who am I to feel great who am I to
be happy that belief system is an
ingrained belief system that can be
cultural that can be something that we
learned from our upbringing it can be
something that we have picked up from
this difficult experience that we're
going through right now with covid when
we witness people suffering we think
well how dare I be happy I would say to
you how dare you not be happy it's your
happiness it's the collective happiness
it's the group Collective happiness that
raises the energetic frequency of the
world if we those of us who have moments
of happiness and Grace and joy and
success and we don't celebrate them we
are doing the world a disservice we are
shutting down the light we are bringing
down the vibration so we we have to when
we feel good we have to reach for more
when we feel good we have to recognize
that that good feeling emotion has
momentum it has power it elevates our
children it elevates our family member
it elevates our friends it elevates
strangers on the street it is your
Divine Duty here on Earth to bring forth
that greatness that goodness that light
so when you hear that voice that says to
you you are not worthy of feeling good I
want you to hear my voice come through
and say to you who are you not to feel
good
this is your Divine Purpose it is your
mission and it is the way that you heal
and serve you got me we are more
comfortable being uncomfortable than we
are being happy
so when things are good and when we
start to get a sense of feeling good
our ego the voice of fear within us
starts to say hell no too good to be
true and it will find these weird little
Corners to pick up problems
we have a fault-finding mindset rather
than a solution happiness oriented
mindset so when that happens the next
time you notice that you're feeling good
and all is well and all of a sudden
you're like but I wasn't nice enough to
that person or my co-workers aren't in a
good place or I didn't do that right I
want you to speak back to that voice I
want you to say thank you for sharing
but I choose happiness instead
thank you for sharing but I don't
believe that voice anymore thank you for
sharing but I'm choosing this moment
give yourself permission in the moment
to speak back to the fault-finding voice
and start to claim the greatness of who
you are that is a pattern because you've
lived your life in a habitual pattern of
seeking problems and finding fault now
we have to redirect and create a new
habit and pattern of grounding you in
the truth of who you are which is
happiness joy peace and Grace sharing
that happiness joy and peace with so
much grace
that's what you're here for
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
how to manifest things in seven days
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
I'll see you there if the person's doing
the vision board and they're saying when
I get my new car I get my new house I
get my new relationship then I'm gonna
feel so great now that well then they're
back